elle est belle je vais t'aimer
rabattement ginette peu pied au festival
rite halal ne peut pas parler comme tout
le monde il faut qu'ils chantent mais tu
m'avais dit le romantisme tu m'avais dit
romantique tu es magnifique somme oui
mais moi le romantisme c'est pas comme
ça que je le vois mal quand je vais au
bal tu comprends rien mais qui me dit tu
prends une bière en fille dans la
voiture
bon moi elle remonte il s'est tu veux
une bière on vit dans la voiture s'il te
plaît
moi ça va faire ses chansons tu m'as dit
à l'ats bal des pompiers étaient madiran
faire la chanson fais des chansons pour
moi je n'écris et unique l'une à ginette
pompiers sur la plus belle quand je
m'approche de tester je ramasse plus
avec le nez avec une paire pour
l'instant pas j'en prends plein les
oreilles tu m'aimes pas la chanson non
pas que c'est voter ça rien si je
promets rien que pour toi jamais fait ça
touche en effet rejeté dit rien on sait
rien c'est la chanson ne soit pas
derrière nous souhaitons des restaurants
avant quand j'ai chanté les gens je
disais qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je
chante disait rien
non mais moi j'ai fait une chanson qui
s'appelle rien même quand ils veulent
rien j'ai aller et après qu'eurent
nantissement me molin parce que là on
sait pas tenir moi ce que je veux être
sait-on vincent scooter toi ce que tu as
well je veux que tu sois mon mal dotées
comprends tu vas te chanter mais
commençait déjà elle est jolie elle est
charmante
non les jolies je vais l'aimer ginette
dupuis ginette plus une note publiée la
plus belle du quartier la plus belle
d'aubervilliers
les journées les chansons à sakhr un
moment les deux mois n'est pas rien la
musique c'est ce qu'entend mémoire la
parole t'as pas l'original et quand j'en
mets toi cette fois que demandeur tu va
réveiller mon vieux
déjà qu'ils rentraient bourrières soir
en plus il s'est acheté un fusil à pompe
c'est en prend un coup dans les fesses
je vais dire un coup de pub tient en
effet ça fait mal moi ça que ça va
c'est la crainte est ton corps bougeait
j'ai même oublié ce que je veux c'est
aimer passer ma vie at elle gardé giner
du pied se veut les garder
ouais mais tu vas me regarder un moment
puis tu vas chanter et chauffée à
quantico livre si je mens près de dix
ans tekori qu'est ce que c'est une
nouvelle pâte
c'est ça et des pâtes des pâtes mais
torticolis non seulement il chante mal
en pis si les cons non merci mais moi ce
que j'aime à 7 mais je me dis que non
pas que tu poses cinq minutes de dans la
rue des glacis désaccord moi ça que
j'avais sauté mais je veux t'épouser je
veux t'épouser gène impliqué hier je
termine un tuner challenge alléchant
monde en arrivant de dieu c'est pas non
je veux t'épouser non pourquoi non parce
que mon arrive pas qu'est ce que je fais
eh ben tu disais merde ça fait rien géré
flotter ma guitare sous les fenêtres de
jeunes chanteurs
j'aurais trop peur